Robin Hood is back on the big screen and
whilst the film is currently being
slammed by critics that doesn't mean
that there aren't things to unpack from
the film throughout this video I'll be
discussing everything you need to know
about the movie as well as how it sets
up potential sequels down the line yeah
they're not gonna happen anyway there
will of course be heavy spoilers so if
you yet to see the film then I suggest
that you turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it
so you don't have to the major twist in
the new Robin Hood film revolves around
will Scarlett played by Jamie Tannen
throughout the film will as the voice of
the people that really rallies them
together however when Robin and little
John managed to kill the original
sheriff will steps up and takes his
place the reasoning behind this is
because will was in love with Marian and
the two even shared a kiss when the
original sheriff lied to her and
informed her that Robin had died during
the Crusades Robin witnessed this kiss
and spent the majority of the movie not
entangling her in his vigil on t
lifestyle because of the danger it could
pose later in the film well is on the
other end of a similar scenario and
witnesses Marian kiss and Robin which
destroys him inside he's green arrow
with Edie
well at this point has been disfigured
by the final battle and naturally feels
embittered about the entire ordeal with
the sheriff now dead Robin and Marian
and their other merry men decide to flee
to the forest but will refuses to join
them the group leave him and probably go
off to film a new reality TV show called
made in Nottingham that's like as I am
Made in Chelsea joke like it's a British
TV show that you might not get it if
here your America you might get it if
you brush but either way it's not really
a good joke so I'll stop now
so we then get a scene involved in the
Cardinal appointing will as the new
sheriff throughout the film the Cardinal
had been wishing to stop the war effort
dead in its tracks and with the original
sheriff gone this role needs to be
filled
well gladly takes it as his hate for
Robin is now a boiling point Robin is a
cause of a lot of anguish for will as
not only did he become mr. steel made he
also ruined any chances of a peaceful
retreat which was the
that well would have preferred the final
fight to go this is obviously put in
place to serve a sequel for the film and
I actually think it would be better than
the film that we got unfortunately the
film is currently bombing at the box
office and with critical reception being
very very low I can imagine that this
will be a storyline that the studio
doesn't want to pick up on it's quite
clearly trying to be a two-faced sort of
origin story but Nolan killed the
building and his masterpiece for a
reason and I doubt we will ever get a
resolution to this plotline so while
your thoughts on the reimagining of
Robin Hood do you agree with the critics
and if not what do you like about the
film comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my review of the
film which will be linked at the end of
this video this is a channel for people
who are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]